joining us now is Byron Donald's U.S
representative for Florida's 19th
district and Pam Bondi former Attorney
General of Florida and and both my
friends all right I will start with you
Congressman Donalds now talk to me about
how Governor Abbott is a racist for
sending immigrants to Lori lightfoot's
Chicago
he's not and listen if you're going to
talk about that then talk about Joe
Biden because Lori Lightfoot wants to
say about this treacherous Journey from
Texas to Chicago but she says nothing of
the treacherous Journey that these
illegal immigrants are taking at the
hands of the drug cartels she says
nothing about the young girls who are
raped on the journey at the hands of the
coyotes and the drug cartels only thing
Lori Lightfoot doesn't like is that she
was shown up by Greg Abbott and frankly
all the Democrats have been because they
wanted to be Sanctuary cities well here
you go now be a sanctuary City but they
like to talk tough they like to talk
like they're they're Progressive but
when it's on their diamond on their
watch they don't want to do anything and
they don't want to lift a finger you
know Pam one of the things that that
Lori Lightfoot and mayor Erica Adams
from New York City uh you know these are
Sanctuary cities which means that for
most of them who can make crimes uh you
know they're going to protect them
they're not going to hand them over to
Long enforcement and even if they commit
a horrific crime they'll be out on bail
anyway and law enforcement won't find
them so these Sanctuary cities provide
Sanctuary for people who enter the
country illegally and for many of them
that we don't know their backgrounds if
they commit another crime they're being
protected so
um why do they continue to be Sanctuary
cities
yeah that's exactly right Janine they're
protected from from being prosecuted for
many crimes and well because she's out
there grandstanding saying we welcome
everyone we love everyone come here
we'll offer you resources we'll protect
you and then when Greg Abbott calls her
Bluff and sends them there she doesn't
know what to do it's like she invited
all these people to a party and then
when they arrived at the party at her
house she said oh I don't want you here
anymore that's exactly what she did I've
known Greg Abbott we were AGS together
I've known Greg for a very long time
that man doesn't have a racist bone in
his body nor a xenophobic bone but what
he is all about protecting Texans
protecting his state from criminals from
Janine I wonder how many drugs these
people brought into this country too we
have no idea fentanyl's out of control
the importation of drugs from Mexico is
is ridiculous now in our country our
kids are dying and Lori Lightfoot is
inviting all of these people into
Chicago what without them being vetted
and so more power to her she's stuck
with them now you know Congressman
Donald's it's very interesting that you
know I heard Joe Biden mention fentanyl
for the first time yesterday and I for
for months have been saying I've never
heard the word come out of his mouth but
you know he said in his safer America
plan well you know we're going to
increase the penalties for fentanyl what
are you talking about you let them out
on bail as soon as you arrest them and
one of the ways to stop fentanyl is to
close the southern border because 95
percent of it comes through the
Southwest border
you're absolutely right judge look the
only reason why he's talking about it
now is because Americans in every city
of our country are dying from fentanyl
it is the number one cause of death
between the ages of 18 and 45 and so
while cities and communities are
struggling with this Joe Biden has said
nothing so it must have shown up in his
polling and now he has to address it but
I got a message for the president if he
wants to stop fentanyl reverse your
policies at the southern border because
what you have done Joe Biden is given
the drug cartels operational control of
the Southern border they're making
billions of dollars trafficking people
into the United States and they're
making billions of dollars trafficking
fentanyl into the United States this is
on you don't talk about criminal
penalties now reverse your policy at the
southern border all right thank you both
very much Pam Bondi Byron Donalds hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else